ANTHONY RIBOT: Good
afternoon, Berlin.
Let's get stuck into things.
A bat and ball cost $1.10.
The bat costs $1
more than the ball.
How much does the ball cost?
Have a little think.
Ready?
Who got this answer?
Hands up, please.
Great.
You got one of two
possible answers.
What you, though, got was
the cognitive miser answer,
the one that used a
shortcut in the brain.
This actually isn't
the real answer.
The real answer is $0.05.
And if you look at the
graphic on that side,
it really does add up to $0.05.
So that's one example of us
thinking that we're rational
but actually acting
irrationally.
The reason behind
the cognitive miser
is that your brain is actually
trying to save mental energy.
The brain is an amazing
thing, and we actually
make, on average, 35,000
decisions in a day.
But that mental energy
is a finite resource,
and we suffer, over
the day, something
called decision fatigue.
So by the end of
it, it's almost as
if we're drunk when
we're making decisions.
But that's just the tip
of the iceberg, really.
Why are we all here today,
and why am I speaking up here?
Well, biases are really,
really important to us
because we're all here to
create apps and experiences that
really offer long-term
relationships
with the customers.
We're all aiming for high
engagement and a high perceived
value from customers
for our products.
But we can use biases in a
positive way, and a guiding
light, and a
simplification process
to guide them through the
journey of our app in a really
nice and simple way.
Two scenarios.
Which would you prefer?
The number involved above is
number of monthly active users
in your app.
I think we'd all agree
that we'd rather 3 million
rather than 800,000.
But let's add one
data point to that--
engagement.
Scenario 1 now has
low engagement,
but scenario 2 has got high.
And by engagement,
I'm defining that
as the percentage of people
completing your core action.
A core action,
for example, would
be posting a tweet on
Twitter, pinning an item
on a board on Pinterest.
So actually, which of
the two would you rather?
I'd highly and strongly
suggest that we actually
focus on the 800,000
and the high engagement.
The 3 million is really
just a vanity metric.
Let's go six months
into the future.
And now we've seen how
focusing on high engagement--
that's leading to
higher retention.
You've been able to build
up the monthly active users
to 5 million.
And so that's with using
these little nudges,
these little biases,
these guiding lights
to help your customers along
the journeys within the apps
that you've built.
Having been in this
business for a long time,
there's a few questions we
ask ourselves when we're
designing and building apps--
simple questions, really.
Is it clear what the app does?
In that first five or
10-second experience
for the customer,
really, how are you
getting the value across?
Are you providing that hook?
In terms of value as well,
generally, to create value,
you either save people
time, save people money,
or enhance an
experience, or it's
a combination of the three.
So think about how
you're actually creating
value for the customer.
And also, going back
to that core action,
try and design that whole
experience of your app
around that specific,
simple core action
and use those biases to
help them along the way
to complete that core action.
Also, along that
journey, how can you
provide a sense of progress
to make them feel like they're
progressing to the end goal?
We live in a very noisy world.
We've got push notifications,
social messages, adverts,
emails, phone calls all from
all sorts of different devices.
We live in an age
of distraction.
With that in mind,
it's never been
more important to
consider a few things--
specifically, context
and past behavior
when you're thinking
about sending
triggers out to your customers.
Even better, there
are now SDKs available
that allow you to look at
the past behavior, the habits
and the lifestyle of your
users, and predict when is best
to send out those push
notifications as used
by [INAUDIBLE]
using the newer SDK.
It's amazing the kinds of
tools that we've got access to.
Also worth considering
are other tools,
like the Google
Awareness API, which
can provide a sense of
context to your app in terms
of what state the user is in.
Are they driving?
Are they walking?
Do they have their
headphones plugged in?
These little nuances to how
and when you're pushing out
triggers really have a
long-term positive effect
on your retention
and engagement.
The power of defaults--
this is often overlooked,
but hugely, hugely useful
to simplifying the
customer's experience.
Here we've got a top-up wheel
for a mobile coffee loyalty
app.
There are seven segments.
Now, the numbers in
green, which one of those
do you think we should
place in the default
highlighted segment
in the wheel?
And you-- again,
give me a shout.
10?
30?
OK.
We've got some
smart people here.
So 30 is correct.
We chose 30 as the
default here because it
was in the middle of the range.
And the end result of that was
that the average top-up value
was roughly around
20 pounds here,
where originally, the
business thought it was
going to be around 10 pounds.
Now, with all these biases
and guiding lights and nudges,
it's great to
integrate into an app.
But it really does have a
positive long-term effect.
And this was the case with this
specific app that 50% of orders
were coming from the app
for a certain source.
And that compares to the market
leader in the coffee space
having an average of 21% of
orders coming from the app.
So these little
nudges really help.
I think a huge number of us have
heard of the classic jam jar
experiment whereby 24 jams
compared to six jams--
the 3% of the people
who are shown 24 jams
buy a jam compared to 40% of
people who buy one of the six.
So that's called the
paradox of choice.
And this applied to
many who design here.
I start off with
showing 50 options.
So you've got every
option under the sun
on the starting screen--
obviously, far too many.
You're introducing cognitive
load into the experience.
You're making the
user work too hard.
So let's just apply some
common sense to that list,
and we end up with
the second screen--
10 options.
This is still a
[INAUDIBLE] list,
but we can do so much
more for the customer.
The ideal could
be just one user--
one option-- the smart,
the perfect option,
the perfect option that takes
into account the context.
That's true, but it's also worth
considering the last screen
on the far-hand side of
providing three options.
Why would you want to
write three options?
To give a sense of
choice to your customer,
to allow them to control their
journey through your app.
All these behavioral
biases are really
stemming from the last
60 years of research
in behavioral science.
But new concepts and
theories are coming out
on a weekly basis.
There's a problem, though,
in that they're really
largely very dry, very academic,
maths-ridden sometimes,
actually hard to get hold
of, and fundamentally, also,
not very practical in
their original form.
So we discovered this particular
problem two or three years ago
and decided to create a little
micro-site called cogload.com
which basically is
a collection of all
these lovely behavioral
biases pulled together
into one location,
but redesigned
and rewritten so that it's in
a format that's digestible,
understandable, and
also practical to us
who are the designers
and developers of today's
products and the future.
So cogload.com, and I might have
something to give out later on.
Will all this
speak about biases,
how best do you integrate
this thinking into the way
that you're designing
and building your apps?
One of the methods
that we've got is--
we call it the cog
load focus method.
We have biases, and on
a whole stack of cards,
we put it all out in the table.
And collectively,
within the team,
we look at what's
most applicable
to that particular
scenario, to that brand.
And we make sure that everyone
understands the biases.
Then you go off in your
individual little corners
of the room and brainstorm ideas
around how to best integrate
that bias into the
experience for the benefit
of the customer.
Also, it's worth keeping
in mind the values
of the client or the product,
the strategy that you've got,
and also think about
the emotion that you're
looking to evoke by someone
using your tool or app.
Then come back together, present
your best idea to the team,
but think about
the actual problem
that you're looking to tackle.
Present the idea, how it
aligns with the brand.
Present also the
assumptions and risks
you think are involved
in that and how
are you going make
that minimal test,
and who's going to
be involved in that.
The Memrise app, one of my most
favorite apps in the world.
And I just wanted
to take a moment
to focus you in
on to the very top
of the screen, the green area.
This is the first time this
screen has been shown to me,
the user, the first-time user.
But there's two ticks here.
This is what's called the
endowed progress effect.
And it's a feeling that you've
already made a great start,
so you're more likely to
progress to that end goal,
completing that line,
developing a positive behavior.
And it all stems from research
originally done in the US
for a car wash who trialed
two different loyalty cards.
The first loyalty
card had eight stamps.
The second loyalty
card had 10 stamps,
but two were pre-filled.
Which was the loyalty card
that performed the best?
It was the one that had
the two pre-filled stamps.
That was the card that was
completed the most often,
that was complete
the quickest, and had
the most loyal customers.
Another lovely graphic here--
the Harvard Business
Review Pyramid.
Now, two things to
take from this slide.
Try and involve as many of
these points in this pyramid as
possible in your app.
And what you will then
create is customer loyalty
and high engagement.
One other thing from this
pyramid is emotion again.
It's really important to
just ask this simple question
when you're designing
and building your app.
What emotion am I
looking to evoke?
It might simply be a smile.
It might be some
stage past emotion,
like salivation, which
is an amusing one.
But it's a very simple
question, and it
acts as a really lovely,
simple guiding light
to making sure that the
value you're creating
is high enough and
beneficial to the customer.
Now, this is an app that I
hope you've all got installed
already on your devices--
Playbook for Developers,
which is a goldmine of nuggets
for anyone building businesses
on top of Google Platforms.
And I just wanted to showcase
two particular biases that
are integrated into the app.
You've got the sunk
cost effect, which
is as you spend more time
investing within a tool
or product, you're far
less likely to leave.
And so over the days or months
that you're using the Playbook
app, you're personalizing
it, so then you're
getting a more
personalized feed,
and again, less likely to leave.
Then there's the humor effect.
It's not really
connected to a feature,
but it's used to really create
a more lasting memory, which
helps with retention.
So we always want to get
darting androids into our apps.
As I also mentioned before,
it's not always about features.
Think about also the low
moments in an app's experience--
when the network
fails, when there's
an internal error within
the app, when you're
in that first default state
where you don't have any
saved items.
How can you use these design
nudges in a positive way
to turn what actually might
feel initially quite negative,
soften that, and maybe
you can even turn that
into a positive experience,
and maybe make someone
smile by showing a cute robot?
The last case study I
wanted to highlight today
is the M. Gemi app, which
is an app that sells shoes.
And the really interesting bias
that they've integrated here
is that of limited availability.
So they have this
notion of editions
that they release
every single week.
But within those
editions, there's
a certain number of shoes-- so
limited availability, actually,
on the shoes.
And then there's
a limited window
of 12 weeks for each shoe.
So the result of all
that-- they ended up
having the highest converting
sales channel on mobile.
That was their
highest-converting sales
channel, and it was four to five
times the industry standards
of conversions of push.
So these things really do
work and are very, very useful
for both customer and client.
All this said-- like I've said
before, with biases come power.
They can be used
for negative effect,
but it's not the
time to use that.
Really, for creating long-term
engagement, retention,
the customer has to be right
at the heart of it all.
And you can use the pulse
devices in so many ways
to create that positive
emotion for the customer.
So always end on a
peak end rule bias,
which creates a
longer-lasting memory.
Find me at the break.
I've got a limited number of
special things to give out.
So limited availability
bias there.
Also, human bias creates
a longer-lasting memory.
Merci, danke, thank you.